One of the great problems of human beings
is that we’re far too good at keeping going.
We’re experts at surrendering to the demands
of the external world, living up to what is
expected of us and getting on with the priorities
as others around us define them. We keep showing
up and being an excellent boy or girl – and
we can pull this magical feat off for up to
decades at a time, without so much as an outward
twitch or crack. Until, suddenly, one day,
much to everyone’s surprise, including our
own, we break. The rupture can take many forms.
We can no longer get out bed. We fall into
a catatonic depression. We develop all-consuming
social anxiety. We refuse to eat. We babble
incoherently. We lose command over part of
our body. We are compelled to do something
extremely scandalous and entirely contrary
to our normal selves. We become wholly paranoid
in a given area. We refuse to play by the
usual rules in our relationship, we have an
affair, ramp up the fighting – or otherwise
poke a very large stick in the wheels of day-to-day
life. Breakdowns are hugely inconvenient for
everyone and so, unsurprisingly, there is
an immediate rush to medicalise the problem
and attempt to excise it from the scene, so
that business as usual can restart. But this
is to misunderstand what is going on when
we break down. A breakdown is not merely a
random piece of madness or malfunction, it
is a very real – albeit very inarticulate
– bid for health. It is an attempt by one
part of our minds to force the other into
a process of growth, self-understanding and
self-development which it has hitherto refused
to undertake. If we can put it paradoxically,
it is an attempt to jumpstart a process of
getting well, properly well, through a stage
of falling very ill. The danger, therefore,
if we merely medicalise a breakdown and attempt
to shift it away at once is that we will miss
the lesson embedded within our sickness. A
breakdown isn’t just a pain, though it is
that too of course; it is an extraordinary
opportunity to learn. The reason we break
down is that we have not, over years, flexed
very much. There were things we needed to
hear inside our minds that we deftly put to
one side, there were messages we needed to
heed, bits of emotional learning and communicating
we didn’t do – and now, after being patient
for so long, far too long, the emotional self
is attempting to make itself heard in the
only way it now knows how. It has become entirely
desperate – and we should understand and
even sympathise with its mute rage. What the
breakdown is telling us above anything else
is that it must no longer be business as usual
– that things have to change or (and this
can be properly frightening to witness) that
death might be preferable. Why can’t we
simply listen to the emotional need calmly
and in good time – and avoid the melodrama
of a breakdown? Because the conscious mind
is inherently lazy and squeamish and so reluctant
to engage with what the breakdown eventually
has to tell it with brutality. For years,
it refuses to listen to a particular sadness;
or there is a dysfunction in a relationship
it is in flight from or there are desires
it sweeps very far under the proverbial carpet.
We can compare the process to a revolution.
For years, the people press the government
to listen to their demands and adjust. For
years, the government makes token gestures
but shuts its ears – until one day, it is
simply too much for the people, who storm
the palace gates, destroy the fine furnishings
and shoot randomly at the innocent and the
guilty. Mostly, in revolutions, there is no
good outcome. The legitimate grievances and
needs of the people are not addressed or even
discovered. There is an ugly civil war – sometimes,
literally, suicide. The same is true of breakdowns.
Yet a good mental physician tries hard to
listen to rather than censor the illness.
They detect within its oddities a plea for
more time for ourselves, for a closer relationship,
for a more honest, fulfilled way of being,
for acceptance for who we really are sexually….
That is why we started to drink, or to become
reclusive or to grow entirely paranoid or
manically seductive. A crisis represents an
appetite for growth that hasn’t found another
way of expressing itself. Many people, after
a horrific few months or years of breakdown,
will say: ‘I don’t know how I’d ever
have gotten well if I hadn’t fallen ill’.
In the midst of a breakdown, we often wonder
whether we have gone mad. We have not. We’re
behaving oddly no doubt, but beneath the surface
agitation, we are on a hidden yet logical
search for health. We haven’t become ill;
we were ill already. Our crisis, if we can
get through it, is an attempt to dislodge
us from a toxic status quo and an insistent
call to rebuild our lives on a more authentic
and sincere basis. Thank you for commenting,
liking and subscribing. We also offer, books,
games, homeware and therapy sessions. To find
out more, follow the link on your screen now.